li I'm gonna start with you why don't
you give us a and just kind of like a
bird's-eye view
overview of how this project got off the
ground and I know you worked with Laura
Ziskin on it the late great Laura Ziskin
so just kind of take us through that
just give us a nice overview of the
project yeah Laura had optioned the
piece from based on a Washington Post
article that Amy Pascal had told her to
go and try to get about a butler and and
she hired Danny strong to begin the
script and and then they came to me I
guess I got Steven Spielberg's backwash
I think Steven was gonna do it and and
did Lincoln and then completed script by
the time you start or well I had written
about four drafts over a year a very
very complicated process putting this
story together because it was pretty
overwhelming to be honest with you with
this article of a White House Butler go
you know it wasn't exactly a blueprint
for a movie but a really fantastic idea
and then and then once we got to the
script where we thought it was at a
pretty good place where we were ready
for directors to start to look at it mr.
Spielberg was very interested and then
we heard mr. Daniels was interested and
mr. Daniels ended up directing the movie
and then from there we collaborated
forever on just Draft after draft over a
three-year period and for me it was it
was actually a really wonderful
experience working with Lee on the
script
knew that there was something very
special here first decision I made was
that it was gonna be about the civil
rights movement it was gonna be the
history of the civil rights movement and
then from there the real breakthrough
and figuring out this story was figure
out there was going to be a father-son
story that the butler's son was gonna be
a civil rights activist because then it
created this triangle of Butler his
serving president who's dealing with the
crisis that the butler son is in the
middle of so it made it so that the
that when the Butler was serving it was
always emotional there was always an
emotional attachment to what was
happening as opposed to him just being a
zealot like fly-on-the-wall and then
within that structure you had the entire
family relationship you have you know
the relationship between glory and Cecil
and then Louis's relationship and his
love interest and then lastly trying to
arc all the presidents and having their
arc towards civil rights and in many
cases it was Louis's character that was
the true leader not the president's the
heart of the movie from me was the
father-son love story and at the heart
of it that's what it is
it's a love story between a father and
his son and I related to it because I
had at the time a 13 year old son that
is you know I say white he says black I
say de he say Knight I say go to bed he
said hell no no so does it ever stop and
so in this movie it sort of comes
together and and it's a beautiful sort
of meeting of the minds and so but it
wasn't until that we shot the bus scene
you know where we're in the bus and and
it was hot in the bus and the kids were
sweating and an I yell action and from
nowhere comes these and they come these
incredible extras you know that are
hooded with KKK cloak-and-dagger and the
Nazis and the swastikas and the crosses
and the screaming and the bus shaking
and and then I get a little nervous and
I'm looking at David and Danny who's in
the scene also I go I go cut because I'm
a little scared and they don't hear me
because I'm in the bus and I say cut and
they don't hear me and I'm terrified I'm
terrified I'm terrified
for the actors for me you know
pandemonium and I realized at that
moment that we that this was not just a
father-and-son story that this was a
bigger story than that and that these
kids were heroes they were fighting to
save the soul of our country and and it
was not just the black kids but the
white kids too that came in and did this
so yeah I mean it was it's a that was my
as Oprah says I was kind of I was
frightened about playing the part you
know cuz I didn't I was I was thinking I
needed to be so specific you know and
and where I was at all times to really
understand and be able to do it because
but just for my family but also it was
like little intervals that were like
four years eight years you know you know
35 didn't maybe I'm 40 and then 59 so I
I guess I just started working on on him
you know first I started to try to
understand the history of the time
you know with a you know you know sort
of a dramaturg kind of point of view and
then understand him and talk to the
people that that knew him or knew Eugene
Allen just to understand that did you
meet white house Butler's I did hire a
butler coach that work with me you know
he was with me that just to teach me the
technical ways of doing everything you
know and also really the philosophy of
being a Butner but moat was kind of it's
a it's not against the rules
but it's an unspoken that they stay a
private that they don't reveal things
that happened Alonso filled with one of
the books I read he he was he was a
butler who wrote about it but rarely do
they write or talk about it so I
actually off-the-record got a chance to
talk to some Butler's from the White
House but I didn't get to go into to the
White House and I moved through the the
kitchens and the pantries with them and
stuff like that but I did I did gather
enough information to be able to to make
it come together you know I think in I
was working on the the movement and
trying to understand that the process of
our lives because the movie was a lot
about our love my love with my wife my
love of my son the prodigal son you know
what I mean it's why all those
experiences that we had together I was
trying to understand how to incorporate
them in my being you know and and then
so then I I started looking at the aging
in terms of events and moments in my
life moments in this character's life
that I could place inside of myself
inside of my body like the way we carry
our
pains and our joys and stuff like that
and then so it put things here and here
and here and as I started to do this
because I work with a movement coach for
a day and it was something he said to me
that was really interesting which was
like the body structure when you move
down and - and I thought to myself oh
I'm moving down from from God or from
heaven into the earth you know - I
returned so I knew I wanted to go
downward so much as ad-libbed I mean
Elijah who plays my younger son Charlie
I mean every scene that he does is an
ad-lib to see you know it's so funny he
kept his packing up all the time and a
lot of things had Harold cave to dinner
was what if I came to dinner for that
particular scene it ease the tension
because we were all just we're in it the
real reason I wanted to do it is because
I thought that the words and the story
was important I am a student of my
history I grew up as an orator in school
reciting speeches from Fannie Lou Hamer
and Sojourner Truth I knew all of
Langston Hughes's poems and I just felt
like oh we have an opportunity to share
this story that really is our nation's
story and I saw it as a gift kind of as
an offering because when you know who
you are and where you've come from you
can walk in a room and it's just you but
you come with with with with the legacy
of your heritage behind you so I wanted
to have that as an offering and I saw
Gloria not just as herself but as a
composite of the women of that era who
held the family together through their
love and their guidance and their dreams
and their hopes but they also had you
know their own fire inside and because
of the times had to repress that and I
wanted to play her with with with a
sense of that repression what do you do
with that sense of longing and and
loneliness for something more you know
we all of us who are women of who get to
live at this time you know
wouldn't understand what that means when
you have what you want to do more than
just keep your floors waxed you know and
and and and in her life everyday she
made a tuna fish sandwich at the same
time and watch the edge at night and
then and after a while then you know
well you want something more than that
and so there's your next-door neighbor
who is Terrence Howard and slow down now
slow down so what do you do so so it was
more than just about you know I'm gonna
you know have an affair whatever it was
about something I you know I need
something what do I do with all of this
what I do with all this and so it
represented a kind of strength but also
a kind of longing and a kind of
loneliness for that time but ultimately
love for the family you know that line
that she says everything that you are
and everything that you have is causing
that Butler is exactly how I've lived my
own life everything that I am and
everything that I have is because those
people who were the Freedom Riders and
those who just my father was a barber
his whole life my mother was a maid my
grandmother was a maid her mother was a
maid and her mother was a slave so I
come from that domestic background and
to me this was a way to honor that for
me one of the things that I loved
playing in this film was we are all
products of our environment and you know
Cecil gains in terms of what forests did
you see at the beginning of the movie he
is born into lynchings his father being
killed in front of him being a
sharecroppers son is a shade above being
a slave so you know living all of a
sudden coming from the south to to
Washington being a butler living a
middle-class life where his kids get to
go to school this is a huge progression
from from what you know what he has
experienced before but I've been born in
the north so my notion of injustice is
is different
I see inequality as something that is
more prevalent to me because I haven't
brought up with in lynching so what he's
prepared to accept I'm not and in my
research obviously not being from this
country what I was so amazed by was the
change this country endured in the 50s
and 60s and the impact that had on
people and literally at that dinner
table you see the death of King is in
that is in that dinner scene you see the
legacy of a trailblazer like Sidney
Poitier what it means for him and what
it means for me
you see politically what's going on in
terms of the the radicalization of a
young man and in terms of being a
panther who was in the sit-ins and how
that reflects on the only I mean I study
John Lewis's life a lot in in doing this
role and his family in Georgia were
apoplectic with fear at the fact that he
was he he had gone and done this he felt
the fear and did it anyway and I just
felt to have all of those elements in
one scene to have all of these these
elements in one film is kind of
extraordinary and you know just a gift
to a group of actors so the things that
you say about starting the film in the
hundred year span you say about our
country go ahead say that yeah I mean
you know she just can't help herself I
love it I know you haven't thrown the
hands up yet you see you see why all of
these people were hired by me no but
again I you know I would defy you to
find another country on planet earth
where you literally have that amount of
change within a century and we are
talking about 1926 to 2008 to have a
sharecroppers son see a black man in the
White House I mean for me it don't tell
my dad I said that because I'm from
Nigeria anyway but you know it's it's
incredible and I think that's why this
film is a love letter to this country
shows how far we've come but I think it
also illustrates how far we have to go
you know you read
about the civil rights movement all you
know doing your due diligence as an
actor you watch footage but to actually
be hosed down to actually be at a
sitting where you are spat at and you
have coffee thrown in your face and you
have to have extras who are whipped into
enough of a frenzy that it feels real
enough that what the camera is catching
feels true and you do it again and again
and again to be on that bus as Lee
described and to have these racial
epithets thrown at you again and again a
bridge where black people were actually
hung that historically that actually
happened on that I found myself so many
times almost having to detach almost
creep out of my own body because my body
was being buffeted I mean the the day we
did the hose we knew we were gonna be
going from actual footage of the
Birmingham hosing to our footage and in
a fit of kindness Lee had it so that it
wasn't as high of a pressure but it just
didn't look right so we had to go higher
and higher and higher with the pressure
until you literally were being
consistently punched in the stomach by
this water and and I remember reading
about the hoses being strong enough that
the bark of trees came off and again and
again and it sorry - um - to feel that
in your body the the admiration I had
for these these kids there were 17 and
18 and to think what I was doing at that
age this the there's this selfishness
the completely navel-gazing sort of
attitude I had that that was the thing
that for me I just I just couldn't get
my head around that the bravery of these
kids when I first read when I first read
Danny script you know I feel
a sense of gratitude and when your I
have felt such a gratitude for those who
came before me who had so little and had
no idea that this day could be possible
but this day could be possible and when
you're in in the the action of
recreating that you just it's
unimaginable the kind of courage that it
took Cecil Gaines one of my favorite
scenes in this movie is when Cecil goes
in and asks for more money ask for more
money and you think about that man and
every man in that position who knows
that you're walking into a room and the
people in that room think that you're
literally less than human and when you
walk in the room don't even look up to
give you eye contact and the courage it
would have taken and how many times he
would have had to think about how am I
gonna say it and what am I gonna say and
and yeah and do I tell my wife and what
happens if he says no and will I be
fired and but he does it anyway that was
his way of being a warrior so to revisit
this you get to see the strength and
power of where you come from look at
what they did just getting up and doing
that day after day after day
still holding and maintaining the value
of the family and and love of the family
and caring of the family in spite of all
that it just makes me it makes me feel
like if they could do that oh my god
what could I do